[Music]
okay so hi everyone I'm really happy to
be here that actually PI data is one of
my breakfast things I do I have a coffee
and I watch my data just to learn some
new stuff and I hopefully are you and
somebody else is going to use it as well
now that a quick disclaimer that I gotta
give it that at the beginning of this
presentation is I'm going to break the
first rule of live demos which is do not
ever give a live demo so I'm gonna
actually do it everything I checked I I
just got it from from the repo that is
publicly available to you guys I
downloaded it to my computer set it up
and this is running so you can do
exactly the same thing okay so if
something goes south I apologize I'll
try to improve it but hopefully
everything will work alright so so first
of all Who am I what would we are doing
as a company and more importantly why do
you want to listen to another talk about
Jupiter notebooks so first of all I'm
Jakob Chaka Khan I work as a data
scientist a deep sense AI I do deep
learning machine learning and I do a
bunch of presentations so so that's one
of one of those and we a deep sense what
we do is we we have quite a few things
that we do actually so one thing is we
just supply deep learning part two to
two problems that our clients bring to
us the second thing we do is we teach
our clients or groups of engineers and
and starting data scientists how to do
it how to do it well how to work on
those problems in your organization and
the third third thing we do is products
we one of the products is is Neptune ml
which is you're gonna see a very quick
cooking later on which is a great tool
to manage your your deep learning
machine learning experiments and now why
do you wanna why do you want to hear
another talk about Jupiter notebooks
well first thing is as I see there is a
ton of things that Jupiter notebook
gives
you that you don't use like I see a ton
of people in my organization where
people just use the plane all the sort
of basic 101 notebook and nothing else
and there is a ton of things that you
should at least know about and not use
them consciously okay so we're going to
talk about the bunch of stuff and and
another disclaimer it's more than ten
things I would really rehab if you got
ten things from it and used it but if
you take just one thing and learn just
one thing during this presentation and
use it in your work I'm gonna be super
super stoked about it okay so everything
is available here at our rep Oh deep
sense AI there's a wrapper for this one
it looks like this and there is a super
quick read me that gives you that
actually the one important thing is just
just source this script just source
configure Neptune SH and it's gonna set
up an environment with everything you
see here and you can just run it you
know it's it should work Lucy
okay so um so let's let's start with
with something that is close to my heart
styling the thing is when you are
working those things on a daily basis
it's pretty cool to have it look cool
you know like have some have some fun in
your life you know look it's something
nice for 20 hours a day well maybe less
so that's something that you probably
know just to say pretty much you know
that that's how regular Drupal notebook
looks like you can go to probably
something like this pretty simply you're
gonna see how to do it
of course it's branded but some of us
needed when we work of your clients need
to give work so stuff like that those
things you know could be useful it could
be helpful and could add value so we're
gonna learn how to do it and and it's
actually super simple you know like
there is a there's a few packages that
you get pretty much you know we've just
pip install you just get tubular themes
that gives you a bunch of nice themes
you know one of them one of the one I'm
using is oceans 16 so that's the one
that you see right here and you can
style different parts of it with Jupiter
themer that I haven't used I have to say
I'm using this
seems very simple way to actually set it
up in the habit and and the presentation
and you're gonna you're gonna have
something like this and you know that's
going to be your your notebook
alright so um now if you want to do more
so that's that that's how the the Martin
will look that's how the you know the
code would look now if you want to do
more all you need to do is access this
this file like there is that there is a
custom CSS file in this location and if
you want to write your own package and
you know a ton of CSS you want to do
some super cool stuff about it not like
me then what you need to do is just
change this file so here very simply you
know if you want to like change this
background add some sort of style to to
the border you know that's you can just
you can just copy your your file dip
Senza Phi in this case and you're gonna
have it exactly you know looking exactly
that way so so that's pretty cool and
and super simple and I would encourage
you to use it like whatever you might
want to add you can you know style it to
the way you want it okay now moving on
to extensions so this is a super super
cool thing that lets you that lets you
go way beyond the you know the general
that is the simple vanilla way of using
notebooks so installing it super simple
again there is a script in there and in
the readme you know you can just run it
but um it's it's very very simple just
two scripts you just install it and then
you configure it and then you have it
and what they give you so um so
extensions are are things that what
you're gonna get is you're gonna get
this this window here in your arm that's
you know you have your regular file
browsing and there is this there's this
top and be extension so this is the end
be extensions and there's a bunch of
them that you can set you know you can
turn on and off and set up in a way you
might want to set it up okay
so um those are extensions and some of
them there's a ton of them you might use
one or many some of them that I think
are quite cool is split cell for
instance so split so as you can see here
you know we have two cells and one of
them you know you you might want to have
them next to each other not you know one
after the other so what you would do is
you would
go ahead and do the splits oh and by the
way table of contents if you're doing a
presentation quite a useful thing
because let it lets you navigate to
whatever you might want to navigate so
in this case split so let's go there and
oh let's split them so I'm gonna wait
that's probably why you should not do
okay
the live demo okay so now did it do it
let's split it and it spits okay cool
and I'm gonna just maybe close it and
that's how spirits it works you're gonna
have two cells you know next to each
other quite useful from time to time you
can use it so in this case I want to
print something here maybe put something
there maybe I want to use it for
debugging or something and it's you know
it could be useful
another thing is a Python - the freaking
version so you know you have some code
you know that is Python - you want to
move it to Python free pretty simple
right so here you have a I'm running the
the Python Python 3 here so of course
it's gonna give me an error and this
would be the correct one and the way to
go from one to the other is just use
this and now if you run it you have
correct Python free code so that's
pretty cool and useful and and very very
simple to use
another thing that you might wanna I'm
gonna just go quickly to the content
another thing that you might want to
have is code folding you know some long
functions you might want to have them
you you might want to just just fold
them right you might not want to show
them all when you're programming or when
you when you approach typing we're
showing it to your client whatever you
might be doing that could be quite
useful not to have it displayed another
thing is limit output so for me what
happened a lot of the times was um I
would have something in and you know
some let's say I'm running some code and
it prints something and I would forget
about the the simple problem that if it
prints too much then your browser will
just go you know down the drain so um
what would happen is I would maybe train
tomorrow and then it would print a ton
of stuff and then I'm dead you know then
it might just kill it at some point and
I would not I wouldn't be able to access
it so what you can do is use limit
output so that's how
I want to show you how to set up stuff
with this and be extension you know
configure tab so you would go to limit
output then you would limit this to a
you know potentially let's say this very
small number of characters 25 we're
going to just refresh it and hopefully
after refreshing this I think I have to
refresh this one and as it does we're
gonna go ahead and print that well
that's quite a long time in a way yeah
now that we have it we're gonna go to
the go to the table of contents it's
here and where is my limit output we
have it and now hopefully the printing
should give us a very you know very
reasonable output not a lot very useful
if you don't wanna run into trouble
printing too much okay cool let's move
forward so now snippet snippets for
every proud copy/paste developer like
myself snippets is something that you
might wanna you might want to have
so what slippers lets you do is you have
this snippets here right and the
snippets lets you you know access a ton
of different snippets that you can just
like paste here so for instance you
forgot how to have this nice nice
markdown so you can just like copy here
copy it here and then edit or maybe
there is a you forgot how to write a
class and you can have it right
so I'm so that's cool but you can also
write your own ones so I wrote a few
just to actually one is I let's say I
don't remember how to how to load
something from from URL so now I'm gonna
run it now that I run it hopefully it's
gonna just get this image from the URL
and put it here cool so that's actually
an image from that from the competition
but we want where you're supposed to
find the crime that the place of crime
actually in Portland so so this is from
the blog read it if you like and now
they can give you also the you know the
sort of answers to life what what you
know what do I need so I need coffee of
course because I didn't get it because I
was trying to configure the system
before the presentation so I need
that now why do you think this code is
is written by a data scientist the
snippet do you know yeah there is non
pay as an import numpy SNP you should
always do if your dataset even if you're
not gonna use it ever just do it you
know I should probably input pandas as
well you know but okay so so we have
that um another thing that you might
wanna that you might want to use is
hiding so hiding you have some really
incredibly ugly function that output
something that is valuable to your
client right I should probably have it a
bit larger sorry for that let's go sir
yeah okay and you can you can just hide
it you know there is a we're gonna just
toggle it and it just eats it up and
leaves just the part that your client
might actually want so that's you know
pretty cool tree filter another thing
super useful if you have a lot of files
that say we're gonna go to the resources
here and I wanna I want to find a code
as a JSON that shows me the snippet so
I'm just writing it and and if you want
to have those snippets you just need to
you just need to paste this JSON into
the NB extension snippets tab which is
here oh well this one yeah and you would
just paste it here okay so if you want
to write it on just you know just plug
them in alright so that's I guess pretty
pretty useful could be pretty useful now
one thing I'm gonna change because there
is there is some spots where I'm gonna
actually want more output and I block
the output so we gonna yeah we're gonna
we're gonna have it on limit unlimited
output now all right probably I need to
restart that that thing okay so now we
had split cells we had a Python
conversion we had code folding limit
output and the snippets which are I
think pretty cool hiding as well and
those two things and the slideshow of
course this is what you're seeing
actually here this is a slideshow made
from that one and you
very simply by just going to view in the
view there is a slideshow and it lets
you access this sort of argument that
you pass a parameter that the defines
what this part of your notebook should
be so that's I think pretty cool alright
now that we have we have that out of
there our way we need to we need to
touch on another very important subject
position which is MAGIX so MAGIX are a
set of set of commands or set of modules
that are loaded by typing a percentage
sign and a name of it or to double so
the idea of double percentage sign or
just a percentage sign there is a list
of those and and I'd encourage you to
just go through them and figure out
which ones you need I'm going to show a
few that I like okay because it's my
talk okay so now first the line the line
command line command means that you have
just one percentage sign and everything
that is in the line is going to execute
it so in this case I want to set up some
environment variables so that's what nf
helps you do then you might actually
want to change the output over of of the
errors in the notebooks from non two to
something that shows you more about the
errors like colors them that's quite
useful thing another thing is you can
you can write to files read from files
load the files and things like that so
in this case I'm gonna just write a very
simple code and write it to the file
Python code that PI and then I might
want to actually I might want to
investigate that code within my within
my yeah within my notebook so I can do
that by just going to working with files
I'm going to show you this pi cut
command what it does so that's the one
and it should open yeah it opens the
file you can just inspect it useful okay
next we're gonna have sorry next we're
gonna have the load the load R gets you
that gets you the code from that file
into the into the cell which
you know which means that you can now
work on it and change it and then write
it to file again of course you can use
it without it but with it it's just
easier faster okay so that's pretty
useful
another thing sorry another thing that
you might want to use is just run the
script so that it what you would do is
run important thing about it is you can
actually run the let's say notebooks and
you're gonna get the outputs from those
notebooks into your notebook right so
you might run another notebook and
there's some plots out put it and you
can have them inside of your notes so
that's you know pretty cool okay now for
debugging you can use pronto profile or
PDB to set up the automatic PDB on every
error inside a notebook so of course if
you want to really go debugging then use
IDE
but um or maybe there is something that
I don't know about but this you know
makes things a bit just a bit easier now
something that I really really like is
um let's say I have an I have an object
in one notebook and I might need it in
another notebook so that's why you how
you store so what you would do is you
just instead of serializing poking it
somewhere and then deepening in other
place you can just just store it and
then access it from another notebook so
that's how worried would you would do
with a magic ed store okay now timing
you can time a function you can time in
line time the cell or you can you can
time it which which is going to mean
you're gonna run multiple runs or over
the over the cell and and figure out
what's that was the timing on that okay
some other things that you might want to
do is if you actually are developing
some stuff in notebooks and use some art
so let's say you develop something in a
module and anyone are like see it in the
notebook and not have to reload the
notebook then you use you use a load
external and out reload or there is
reload external as well that you could
use so that's something that is very
useful and that's you're not refresh
your notebook at all
okay so P doc and and and the question
mark they let you see the docstrings of
of a function or a class
in line so you're gonna just check out
what is you know what is that I'm sorry
explanation
I'm sorry dog strings and what is what
is support what this function is
supposed to be doing and and finally
there is uh out of those simple stuff
there is matplotlib in line that
probably everyone or half of the half of
the room has used other there is some
other backends to my plot that you can
use this for is this motley notebook
that will let you have some level of
interactivity so that's also pretty cool
okay now moving on we have some magic
and in so magic you can you can actually
run a bunch of different languages
inside of a cell and sort of create a
polyglot pipeline with all sorts of
different languages so that's quite
useful you can write latte as well if
that's what you love doing and and have
it in out put it in a notebook anyone
knows what's that wasn't say what was
those those equations are about what is
it what is it yeah yeah I hear it from
them from around the room yeah Bosch
normalization that's that's exactly that
okay you can yeah right to file that's
that's what we saw and you can run some
run scripts so write something as if it
were a bash script and you write it and
you have it so that's that's pretty cool
now if you want to find some other
magics you can there is out there's a
bunch of packages that you might want to
find like this one watermarks your
notebook just shows you the you know
just shows you when it was created what
are the versions of Python and some
other stuff like that very very cool now
you can also create your own magic and
and it's not that difficult you just
need to create an in in this sort of
form so here I'm decorating this class
with magics class I'm decorating
decorating the method with line magic
and call it a snapshot and what this is
going to be doing is it will give me the
snapshot of a folder so I'm gonna pass a
folder in the number of pictures that I
want to have from this folder and I can
just see them in
in in my cell pretty useful you can of
course write your own metrics that's
that's why this you know this is here
okay now moving on we gonna we going to
touch on another very important part of
notebooks that is heavily underused
which is interactivity that's for me
that's that's why those notebooks are
you know the super cool okay so let's go
to interactivity and now we have I
figured I'm gonna just show it show it
to you here because okay because you
know it's supposed to be interactive so
I want to I want to show you that so we
have our you can you can create your
sliders you can create your you know
let's say range sliders you know that
that lets you did let you know select
the range you can you can have some
buttons that choose some stuff let's say
you might want to have you you might
want to multi select a few models into
your that's a comparison plot you might
want to type some words in order to get
the in order to get the let's say the
sentiment of your model on that on the
text a sort of online and and I'm gonna
show you how to combine them and what
what sort of binds them together is
interact so so in this case I'm gonna
just show you very simply how how I'm
combining two of them one is just show
me how many rows I might wanna have and
it just gonna plot the rows here and
then let's say I'm gonna select I'm
gonna select well yeah it eats it so my
mistake I should have moved little bit
maybe I was styling too much and how you
can you can interact with this and a
multi select and change this and of
course we're talking it's it's very
useful as well now if you really want to
use those if you really want to use that
use it for for working with upon those
data frames then use cue grid and and
cue grid yeah cue grid lets you do even
more so we can let's say you wanna you
wanna sort on this one or you might
wanna on this on this column you might
want to do something like this and then
you have it so it's very very useful if
you actually want to do something
interactive and palm doesn't do it okay
now some other other things that might
might be
very interesting to to you is it's here
we have we have yeah all right let's
move on yeah this place so this place
lets you for instance you can you can
see the the video so you can have a
video and you can actually in the
presentation you can run it it should
work and it does right so so that's
pretty cool you can it works for YouTube
as well another thing you might wanna
you might want to do is is you might
want to you might want to actually have
some HTML that does something rendered
inside of yourself so in this case let's
say I want to investigate mr. Potato
Head and mr. Potato Head gets
investigated on under the microscope so
that could be very useful for tasks like
a segmentation or something like that
where you want to see how well your your
model is doing on a particular image and
maybe a lot of those images you want to
have displayed here and then you want to
just like microscope them one and and
and see what's wrong with your model so
other stuff that you could do let's say
you want to read a paper of course you
can read the paper inside of your
Jupiter notebooks why not if you wanna
if you want to actually have a web page
inside of it you can as well you can
embed it an iframe and this is actually
an experiment that I started four hours
ago for for the competition see discount
on cable right now we we actually ran a
started as a city scale starter kit
where you can extend it and you can you
can run it with with Neptune ml and and
have your experiments within this
architecture and also you actually can
compute for free first hundred hours is
for free give or take hundred bucks and
GCP so that's that's really cool
check it out on on our on our repo okay
so now that we we have that we're gonna
move move on one last thing that I
really want to show you is bouquet
because bouquet is beautiful bouquet
lets you actually do even more
interactive stuff so that's a very
simple example or where I'm outputting a
an image and then I want to have some
functionality like I like hover tip all
over it so so I can you know that gives
you this you could you have hover tip
and you can invest maybe there's a lot
of points on your on your plot and you
just want to see
you know in detail only a few so on
however you're gonna get it a ton of
different stuff like link plots although
those don't work with notebook but a ton
of different things that you could use
here very useful and yeah and I'm sorry
alright okay so um I think that's that's
it for me
thank you thank you very much if you're
interested in talking about Jupiter
notebooks
or or what we do or anything there is a
booth here kodaline distance is part of
called align and of course we're hiring
so if you're interested just give us
give us a call all right thank you very
much after mysterious sign you have spit
it up so much that you guys so every
time a time for a few questions
sure yeah there's a question back with
PDFs all right going back to PDF part go
back to PDF alright I think it's here
yeah uh-huh
was that can I read local foul yeah of
course I'm actually reading local foul
here
it's from resource Gump eat paper yeah
yeah you can you can definitely read
them mm-hmm one more just wondering
what's the sort of best practice for
working with virtual environments with
ipython notebooks would you insult them
in there or would you have a new kernel
yeah um there is actually I'm actually
showing and there is a section as well
with in the wrapper with some useful
stuff that I didn't mention yeah I
definitely I'm definitely using a bunch
of kernels that I that I can just reload
in my notebook
so adding the kernel to a notebook and
then deleting it from a kernel is it's
covered there yeah but um one thing that
I that I haven't really worked on is how
to have different styling in different
environments so I'm actually have one
stock ship one styling for my machine
and because that's a global dot Jupiter
custom custom CSS I'm sure you can have
it within the environment but I didn't I
didn't I didn't do it so I don't
okay so thank you so much for talk
applause please
you